welcome to this video I'm playing snuba
cinder bird from from Germany the
caro-kann might have 690 could I could
play 97 here mixing variations okay it's
going to g3 Alice's of course a
well-known alternative it's not very
very ambitious but but playable of
course here should i go b6 and sour
Liam's and only be six that why not get
the bishop to be seven interesting
should I play maybe i showed you i play
a six so they don't 85 i have b5 yeah
he's playing very quickly basically just
developing without any of any clear
target ok oh this is certainly possible
nothing scary for black but of course he
can play that ok maybe just take the
fall this is probably a simple solution
yeah now he just has some the isolated
pawn I don't don't really know if this
is such a good isolated pawn
I feel that I have a very decent
activity here um what about the e5
Knight mean yeah I can take it which
would which would allow the isolated
pawn to may I do that to take only five
persuade that he doesn't even do it
that's strange really okay d 5 58 was
also fine form fine for black let's um
let's see putting some pressure on d5
what I must avoid is Queen B form then
Bishop takes d5 as a problem you might
be able to take your take on b6 that's
not really a big threat or anything but
it's it's possible maybe 85 couldn't be
formed yeah I need to be a bit cause
that played him a number of times and my
results are terrible i've got one point
out of six which is pretty weird but i
tend to lose totally winning positions
against him not quite sure why but it
seems that i don't really I don't really
play well against him ok I can go I can
go Quinn before that's not not bad
really takes takes can give the check
but the endgame is good for me at the
end I believe that's playing this very
quickly the end game is good for lucky
check because of my attack on da porn
yeah this is this is just just wrong
what he's doing this quick yeah now
Knoblauch is is substantially better and
he decided on that super quickly
the problem was that a phone was hanging
and he has a week back rank so he needed
to play be three maybe and now i'm just
getting active maybe he can hold this
with a five the anthesis may be possible
he can maybe play rook c 3 a 5 takes
rook takes and then he's attacking okay
yeah it's probably probably still okay
for blood elf or white I'm sorry mmm is
that way around that brooksy 385 takes
probably not and that's very unfortunate
maybe I shouldn't have played rook c8
hmm okay maybe it was was still ok it it
wasn't a great idea why haven't you to
play this to play this this stuff but
it's still it's still okay
you draw our third game drawn I said
have one minute to India I can make
quite a lot of museum yeah hmm that's
really a shame because I always hate it
when they play is stuff instantly let's
not really sure it from for them but ok
here it's just about ok it's just about
ok because of the 85 counterplay um yeah
this is why I cannot I thought I would
be able to enter but it's not happening
he can play be three or king of one
those moves because every time I moved
the rook away he has this this a 5
resource this this for example is is
quite quite similar it always has enough
counter play with the f5 milles do I
have some day then I need to improve
here because black is for sure okay here
he does not really have such a great
position him with the isolated pawn I'm
puter place this move and gives black
III edge darkness I didn't think of yeah
the problem was also that I'm that I
evaluated the endgame is being good for
me thought it would be quite a neat trap
actually but it wasn't yeah here the
problem is he cannot take on b6 this
tends to be very problematic
and what is this what is this move from
problem I know something like this I
have a very have a very safe blockade on
on d5 and d4 is really a is really i'm
hanging now it's not the easy fam if you
have here consider this for example i
just take and drop back this is the rock
on d5 least a week yeah that's very nice
actually yeah I'm I completely misjudged
the ending due to the a5 the a5 resource
check this was my miss evaluation rook
c8 a five okay yeah thanks for watching